[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv soixante dix huit pour
cette nouvelle émission de fin d'année
la rédaction est réuni et vous a préparé
un rendez vous spécial pour un passage
tout en douceur vers 2019 bonsoir c'est
aussi ce soir
bonsoir et bienvenue merci donc de nous
rejoindre au cours de la prochaine heure
nous parlons de l'engouement pour les
jouets rétro du retour de la pottermania
il sera aussi question est des
traditions de noël nous irons jusqu'au
brésil à la rencontre et illinois en
plein tour du monde sur ce plateau
également dylan à 14 ans ce jeune garçon
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines a été
demi-finaliste à ce vent et sans non
plus tard il rejoint le groupe des kids
united
une professeure de crossfit nous donnera
aussi ses conseils pour garder la forme
après lé réveillon et puis elle nous
n'oublions pas nos amis les bêtes avec
l'opération noël de l aspa il y aura
aussi de nombreux autres rendez vous à
découvrir tout au long de l émission et
marylène c'est avec vous qu'on va être
débuté pour se plonger dans l'esprit de
noël
direction le château de breteuil oui le
château qui connu pour ses contes de
perrault animé il ne fait pas l'impasse
sur noël la demeure séparer de ses
d'irlande et nous l'avons visitée dès le
jardin on comprend que c'est noël au
château de breteuil
pour découvrir l'ensemble des
décorations
jean-emmanuel chars aux administrateurs
de la demeure nous la fait visiter
le circuit sera décoré dans cette
ambiance festive jusqu'à la fin des
vacances de noël
c'est un travail de plus de 15 jours
réalisée par lydie paim la jardinière et
paula da silva l'intendant dans la salle
à manger du personnel du château
l'ambiance qui reconstituent et s'est
déroulé en mai 1905 lorsque le roi
edouard vii d'angleterre est venu
déjeuner au château
son chauffeur est reçu à table par le
personnel qui leur soient dignement
on a en plus évidemment la fée des
décors de noël avec ce magnifique sapin
est un thème rouge cette année d'un
salle du château sont proposés à la
visite et reconstitue son histoire et
donc c'est l'ambiance début de siècle du
xxème siècle reconstituée la maîtresse
de maison très jolie robe est descendu
superviser les derniers préparatifs pour
le déjeuner donné ses consignes aux
chefs cuisiniers quand on monte les
étages on arrive dans les pièces des
propriétaires avec une table de noël ou
curieuses invité et je suis sûr qu'on
rouge qui côtoie barbe-bleue et le
prince charmant cendrillon ou le marquis
de carabas pièces maîtresses cette année
une robe de réveillon dans le salon de
musique créée à partir de branches de
sapin
on est très content de cette nouveauté
on espère comme ça crée une nouvelle
robe chaque année à partir de 2018
chaque personnage du château a droit à
son décor spécial les chats bottés qui
sont la mascotte du château ils auront
d'autres que l'on retrouve un peu
partout le long circuit de la visite ici
dans la bibliothèque vous avez le chat
libraires et son élève et qui sont très
bien entouré d'un magnifique village de
noël
si sapins sont répartis tout au long de
la visite le plus somptueux étant
réservé à la grande galerie hommes sont
dans la grande galerie du château où il
ya les plus grands portraits de famille
et puis certains portraits royaux effet
dans cette pièce que nous avons mis le
plus grand sapin il fait 4 mètres
cinquante de hauteur
et puis de l'autre côté de la cheminée
le père noël est un fauteuil attendent
les visiteurs qui veulent se faire
prendre en photo la visite du château se
fait tous les après midi et pour les
vacances scolaires aux commandes de
votre compte
jean emmanuel charlot administrateur du
château de breteuil est en plateau avec
une bienvenue sur ce plateau pour soir
bonsoir
on va donc parler un petit peu plus de
ce qui est proposé le château de
breteuil malaise alors dans le reportage
on voit la visite du château mais il ya
aussi les scènes de compte est justement
une nouvelle arrive pendant les vacances
tout à fait c'est barbe-bleue
barbe-bleue existait déjà mais nous
l'avons entièrement rénové c'est un peu
désuète et on l'a mise au goût du jour
tout comme on avait déjà précédemment
fait pour cendrillon ou peau d'âne
cette année c'est barbe bleue qui va
être entièrement en son et lumière et
qui vatry donc inauguré au rang des
vacances de noël un as du sud ça a été
fait par christophe leur est tout à fait
notre scénographe habituel et qui dans
chaque scène de comptes apporte une
nouvelle innovation une nouvelle touche
et cette fois ci c'est la femme de barbe
bleue qui va apparaître disparaître il
ya des fantômes qui vont parler les plex
les ex femme
voilà c'était ma fille allait néanmoins
oui oui tout à fait tout à fait alors ça
reste un décompte qui peut-être font le
plus peur et encore on a veillé à ce que
la fin soit heureuse et que les enfants
ne sortent pas du tout traumatisme
qu'elle assure néanmoins renouvelé
chaque année les thèmes pour noël on
faire revenir le public aussi parce que
ces deux buts effectivement alors là le
doc c'est vraiment barbe bleue qui va
être la grande nouveauté on renouvelle
aussi avec des comptes différents
racontée par les conteuses donc l'aller
les grossesses spécialement pour noël
c'est effectivement effectivement donc
il ya comme vous avez toute l'année des
contes de perrault
pendant les vacances de noël la conteuse
va glisser un conte de noël au milieu
des contes de perrault ou même comme de
galettes pour la fin des vacances de
noël ce sera plutôt content de galettes
puisqu'on se rapprochera de l'épiphanie
qu'on m'oublie aucune des périodes
ici on parle du château en général y a
toujours toutes ces activités il y a
toujours toutes ces activités la visite
guidée bien sûr c'est quand même
l'élément essentiel de la visite du
château là toutes les pièces du château
toutes les cheminées
tout est décoré il ya six à pain
répartis sur le circuit la visite
et puis déboule des guirlandes ça
clignote dans toutes les pièces c'est
assez féerique
voilà pendant tout le mois de décembre
et une bonne partie du mois de janvier
aussi avec toujours une bonne
fréquentation sur cette période là oui
oui oui s'il ya un mois qu'il y ait
trois mètres de neige
on a beaucoup de monde ça permet aussi
dans les vacances de noël être dans le
ton de noël avec de la neige aussi
exactement breteuil c'est
essentiellement une sortie familiale est
effectivement noël est la période de
l'année où les familles sont réunis il
ya les cousins qui sont ensemble chez
les grands parents
donc on a effectivement beaucoup de
monde pendant ces quinze jours de
vacances scolaires et on peut retrouver
toutes les éléments pour préparer votre
visite au château sur le site internet
qui va se fait chez opel d'écran
effectivement www.beille.fr là on est
dans l'esprit de noël le moment de noël
il ya d'autres rendez-vous déjà
planifiés pour la suite on en profite
ah oui toute l'année
il y aura les grandes chasses aux oeufs
pour pâques bien sûr on peut déjà noter
dans les agendas
et puis entre les deux il ya moult week
end avec différentes manifestations tous
à une strate visible sur le site
on est en train d plié de méditer
pendant le dépliant 2019 qui sera
diffusée un peu partout pour les
vacances de février il y aura également
les ateliers de sophie pendant les
vacances de février
je crois de 2019 c'est une année
anniversaire 2019 ce sera le 50e
anniversaire de l'ouverture du château
au public en 1969
henri françois et séverine de breteuil
on vers un château en v et à deux pièces
au début trois pièces 4 pièces oui ça a
permis de réaffirmer leurs actes
ouverture au poids là les premiers
personnages de cire qui sont arrivés
tout ça s'est fait petit à petit
né en 1969 c'était le début d'une grande
aventure et maintenant 50 ans après le
château est en bon état grâce aux
visiteurs qui sont les mécènes régulier
récurrent de breteuil et profitez en
donc pour aller découvrir ce château pas
forcément sous la neige mais en tout cas
dans l'esprit de noël j'emmène les chars
vous restez encore en plateau un petit
peu avec nous pour ce rendez vous
spécial sur tv 78 ha qui se poursuit et
qui dit noël dit cadeau aurélie on va se
replonger en enfance avec vous c'est une
des grandes tendances de cette année les
jouets rétro vintage qui reviennent à la
mode
et oui noël 2018 ne sera pas uniquement
high tech puisque selon une étude
opinionway
un français sur deux serait nostalgique
de ces jouets d'enfance et j'imagine que
c'est le cas également sur ce plateau
on va faire un petit tour de table
justement wilfried je commence par vous
ans la voilà six mois par mois votre
jouet préféré qu'on vous étions jouets
préférés
c'est mon jouet préféré je ne sais pas
les voitures télécommandées peut-être ce
genre de choses là voilà manon j'ai
beaucoup joué avec les barbies baisse
dans les clichés pour l'instant j'étais
très peu mobile un septième pas par bin
non conditionnels débat revient à son
meilleur
des voix s'étaient les zones restent
dans l'écrit noël jour emmanuel c'est
plutôt les jeux de construction les
maisons en bois on prévoyait
l'emplacement de la fenêtre remplacement
de la porte
la cheminée fallait pas l'oublier capela
les exactement et vous gagnerez mois des
pokemon co et rogers
vous apprécierez l'âge de chacune des
personnes autour de la table en fonction
de ce jouet en tout cas tout s'est joué
mais on les retrouve un dans les rayons
à des enseignes spécialisées des jouets
qui ont été réédités pour certains qui
ont eu un petit coup de jeune on est
allé vérifier ça à rambouillet on va
retrouver des reproductions de ces mêmes
produits qui n'existaient plus ces
dernières années qui sont ressortis ces
derniers temps pour justement satisfaire
là on est plus sur une demande en fait
des parents le magnétophone à cassette
donc là c'est la fidèle reproduction
de la version en 2018 donc ya pas de mp3
ça reste toujours la petite cassette
audio également le téléphone classique
attiré donc là c'est pas le smartphone
vous êtes vraiment sûr le téléphone très
classique qui existait dans les années
80 également vous allez avoir le kiki de
tous les kikis donc en fait il a été
renommé monchy schiste et le nom
original et ça c'est pareil c'est une
tendance qui joue ça joue beaucoup sur
le nostalgie on a évidemment à la
renvoie les caméras j'imagine la
génération 50 équipes images on voit la
cdm chichi puisque en fait le nom a
changé en 2013 suite au rachat de la
marque
on remercie d'ailleurs mélanie qui nous
a prêté son kiki voilà parce qu'il faut
bien dire non chichi en fait aujourd'hui
ce qui était d'ailleurs voilà évidemment
alors dans les rayons on a pu voir
également plusieurs d'anciens jouets
chez fisher price en fait il était très
populaire dans les années 60 70
ils ont été donc réédité mais en fait
ils sont distribués par une entreprise
qui est bien connu sur territoire saint
quentin en yvelines
l'entreprise asmodée alors j'ai avec moi
sur ce plateau notamment une réduction
du jeu le fermier a dit il avait été
lancée en 1965 en fait c'était à
l'époque le tout premier jouer je vous
fais passer on pouvait en fait on pense
des différences sont un des animaux on a
juste à aller jobs a tiré en fait faut
juste irez vous avez vous avez dans
l'allemand sur le côté oui mais une fois
dessus et voilà maintenant fonctionner
un jouet
c'est bien voilà et alors c'est dessiner
évidemment mieux d'écouter l'émission un
public assez jeune à partir de 18 mois
c'est ça vaut à peu près 30 euros il ya
également cette télévision musicale
c'était la première donc été qui est
sorti en 1966 était pour les enfants de
12 mois et plus
il ya des comptines ce qu'il ya c'est
que si je mets le avec lui on va voir
plein de son collège ou à ce qu'ils
soient rue pour leur tranquillité des
parents les tablettes c'est beaucoup
plus calme c'était donc la première télé
musicales dont qui est sorti en 1966 et
puis troisième objets vintage également
distribué distribué par asmodée l
appareil photo à fisher price donc qui
est sorti en 1968 il ya des disques à
insérer on peut donc voir des histoires
de boucle d'or notamment
voilà donc c'est un design vraiment vite
edge vintage qui arrive ça peut paraître
assez désuet mais en fait c'est vraiment
une vraie demande un aujourd'hui une
vraie demande évidemment des parents
puisque à cette notion de transmission
qui est important pour les parents et
puis en fait la conclusion c'est que
même si on prend de l'âge
on reste tous deux très grands enfants
il est échoué que vous avez eu les uns
les autres
non non encore pensions alors patrick
jacq de 10 mhz qui est donc tu fais
partie de la rédaction m'a dit que voilà
il avait connu on fait un petit plomb
sur patrice
lyon voilà voilà voilà mais c'est plutôt
voilà nos parents oui mais bon je vois
ça tu vas faire des sept noms et les
enfants comment alors les enfants
véritablement arrive à se prendre à ce
genre de jouer malgré la concurrence des
télécentres parce que c'est quand même
plus un désir des parents fait voilà
d'avoir le plaisir de revoir les jouets
de leur enfance dans quelques instants
c'est dylan djembé zimling qui est
nouveau membre des kids united et qui
figure sur l'album l'esprit de noël qui
viendra interpréter vive le vent sur ce
plateau avant de l écouter elle chantait
c'est vous qui allez donner de la voix
micro-trottoir compilées par patrick
jacques de dixmude et miquel et demi
d'euros et merci encore à vous d'être
venu sur ce plateau côtier décembre et
du ciel tir faute à bien se couvrir
c'est rosa bien sûr ici
euros
les sept ans
et ça
alain
li na
être au lit ce cas
n'est ce pas
teach feliz navidad petit papa noël
quand tu descendras du ciel avec
tes souliers par milliers ben
oriane fans sautent un ennemi
si massa
à
[Musique]
en août 2017 les téléspectateurs
découvrent dylan 13 ans ce jeune évinois
participe à la quatrième saison de the
voice kid il arrive jusqu'en demi-finale
et depuis il poursuit son chemin musical
un album sardou et noué en mai dernier
les kids united nouvelle génération et
il est avec nous en plateau ce soir pour
nous interpréter visiblement
[Musique]
vive le vent vive le vent vive le vent
d'hiver qui sont pas si plus l'on se
plante dans les grands sapins verts
hommes vivent le temps fit équipes
luttant et bible ton divers
boule de neige et jour de l'an est bonne
et grand mère sur le long chemin chou
blanc de neige blanche où un vieux
monsieur s'avance avec sa canne dans la
main étaient tous là haut le vent qui
siffle dans les branches puisque plus la
romance qu'il chantait petit empan vive
le vent vive le vent vive le vent
d'hiver qui sont 26 points ce plan dans
les grands afin vert or bible tant pis
des dits flottants bible temps d'hiver
boule de neige et ce jour de une bonne
mais grand mère
[Musique]
à
et le vieux monsieur descend vers le
village c'est l'heure où tout est sage
on dans ce coin du feu et dans chaque
maison
il flotte un air de fête partout la
table est prête et l'on entend la même
chanson how big deux camps vive le vent
vive le pont divers
ils sont pas si forts soufflant dans les
grands à part des routes émeute ont vidé
vive le temps bible temps d'hiver boule
de neige et jour d'heure et par une
année comme air joyeux joyeux noël
mais bozik on chante dans le ciel les
classes jeu de nuit au biberon des bleus
vont vite le banc des verts
sova si peu en soufflant dans les grands
sapins verts en béton fib le temps libre
le ton dix belles boules de neige et
soudeurs et par année dans mr
[Musique]
lalala lalala lalala lalala rang
by blow by blow
vive le vent d'hiver et 126 points
soufflant dans les grands sapins verts
au bouquet de thym bbbb temps
piton des neiges
bo de neige et son odeur et bonne année
secondaire
merci zen alors on déploie pas derrière
la caméra mais il y avait quelques il ya
un petit public apprenne qui était très
ému et très contente d'être là où
chansons tout à propos pour la saison
c'est dans l'album l'esprit de noël qui
est sorti le 23 novembre dernier ça fait
encore une corde à son arc encore
beaucoup de projets alors pourquoi tu as
choisi de vivre le vent parce que c'est
une chanson que tout le monde connait
c'est quand même un classique de noël et
je me suis dit que c'était bien de
reprendre cette chanson puisque c'est
une belle chanson mais j'adore la
chanter et tu as a means et de touche au
jazz et c'est toi qui l'a voulu alors
bah c'est un album qui a été créée par
mon directeur artistique
jérémy chapron donc qui a réalisé
l'album et il s'est dit que ça serait
bien de faire un album de noël comme à
l'américaine et faire un truc un peu
jazz mais avec des classiques de noël
comme ça et de les rendre un peu plus un
peu plus mature que ça te plaise ce
rythme-là jazz justement un peu bas je
trouve ça très anti nation d'assez plus
intéressant que la version de plus
cantine d'enfants et samedi
alors depuis quelques mois non il ya eu
sa participation à the voice qui dit
d'abord et tout s'est accéléré
exact est vraiment suivi cette aventure
ce qu'on me rappelles tu as alors tu
avais 13 ans lors de l'époque mais
maintenant quand on a 14 que mon fils à
14 ans belge devient un peu comme un
rêve un cas des veillées c'est assez
incroyable parce que j'ai rien demandé
enfin on est venu me chercher et du coup
du jour au lendemain ça a basculé j'ai
fait the voice guide ce qui m'a amené à
faire tous les projets après eux et
c'est incroyable c'est vrai que ça s'est
très vite enchaîné et je réalise pas que
tu fais aussi partie de la nouvelle
génération des crises united qu'est ce
qui t'a qu'est ce qui t'a plu quand on
te l'a proposé qu'est ce qui te plaît
aujourd'hui dans ce projet ce qui m'a
plu et ce qui m'a vraiment donné envie
de travailler avec des liquides c'est le
fait qu'on est ambassadeur de l'unicef
et on aide beaucoup d'enfants chaque
album vendu c'est un euro reversé à
l'unicef pareil pour les places de
concert et ça c'est le plus important
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants dans
le monde qui souffrent surtout dans les
pays en afrique et ça me fait super
plaisir de me dire que j'ai des enfants
d'un avec ma passion alors j'imagine que
c'est très prenant
l'école les répétitions comment est ce
que tu fais tout pour tous pour tous
considérés comme tu veux c'est assez à
l'aise avec la production on s'arrange
pour vraiment quasiment jamais loupé
l'école
ça arrive très rarement et quand on a
des rendez vous c'est le mercredi et le
week end
ou alors de temps en temps des
exceptions où on enregistre en semaine
et voilà j'imagine que les parents les
amis sont ici très présent pour t d est
accompagné ses saveurs oui puisque vu
que je suis mineur et ben il faut
toujours un adulte est avec moi que ce
soit mes parents bien lors de mes amis
de la famille donc ouais juste jamais le
trac oui bah c'est sympa si jamais parce
qu'il va pas du tout ils attendaient
patiemment leur monde chantait il a
chanté il a fait ses choix ses limites
on n'est pas présent là c'est vrai qu'au
début j'avais un peu le trac parce que
c'était ma s'étaient tous nos bovins je
faisais des petits spectacles d'école
dans de basses chez moi et il a dû jour
en scène de spectacles avec des palais
des sports des aînés notamment à livrer
et c'est vrai que c'est incroyable du
coup j'ai déjà fait une tournée qui
s'appelait qu'ils attisent and friends
avec les anciens kid et vu qu'il avait
beaucoup d'expérience ils nous ont
beaucoup appris qu'il y avait moi qui
les avons rejoints et on a beaucoup
appris d'eux et on a vu qu'en fait ça
serve à rien de stresser et qu' il
fallait plutôt ceux en profiter du
moment parce que c'est quand même assez
incroyable à notre âge et c'est pour ça
qu'à l'heure d'aujourd'hui je stresse
plus trop où je profite si certains
croient parce que tu pars en tournée le
27 janvier c'est la première date mec
l'utilisent 30 dates 2 au palais des
sports de paris vous allez devoir y
avait un petit agenda pour défendre au
bout de nous-mêmes et là qui est déjà
vendu à 80 mille exemplaires y eu un
petit mot petiot les chansons dedans
c'est pas du tout de talent génération y
attaquante du bourvil
mais j'imagine que tout le monde peut
tout chanter beta je sais ça qui est
intéressant avec l'album au bout de nos
rêves c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
chansons que les parents connaissent et
les grands parents aussi cédé trading
chanson la plus vieille c'est la
tendresse de boer vue de notre premier
single et c'est intéressant parce que du
coup quand on vois en concert ont fait
découvrir aux enfants les les anciennes
chansons qui peuvent aussi les chanter
et les parents qui sont aussi bien
contents de venir assister et danton
lors leurs chansons qu'ils ont chanté
candy quand ils étaient plus jeunes que
vous avez écouté les morceaux d'origine
ou alors vous êtes parti libre pour
votre interprétation et puis après vous
avez comparé d'être du coup pour ma part
je
je pense qu'ils ont fait exactement la
même chose des otites j'ai écouté les
versions originales et après j'ai essayé
d'aller voir s'il y avait des covers y
est après je les chante et je les chante
et pour rajouter notre petit grain de
sel et rendre ça un peu plus moderne et
que les enfants mac et pc mais quoi
merci beaucoup dylan alors pour
t'écouter et découvrir tes projets je le
rappelle il ya deux albums l'esprit de
noël
il est si et qui dit night 4 la nouvelle
génération et la tournée à suivre dylan
est ce que tu es fan de harry potter ou
pas j'adore harry potter harry potter et
fera partie de ceux qui vont être
recevoir des cadeaux harry potter la
pottermania est de retour michael et
demi d'euros est allez le constater sur
place
après 45 minutes de transport achmed
arrive enfin dans son lieu préféré son
poudlard à lui une boutique versailles
est spécialisée dans les produits
dérivés harry potter après avoir regardé
les huit films en trois jours ce
passionné a craqué s'est décidé à faire
chauffer une nouvelle fois la carte
bleue en fait je pense que l'univers et
nous a tellement inspiré on se sent s'y
sent tellement bien en fait quand on
quand on se plonge dedans qu'on a envie
d'avoir
voilà des petits trucs qui qui nous
permettent d'y rester en fait c'est en
s'entourant petit à petit de tous ces
trucs là on se dit en fait moi aussi je
veux en faire partie
pour répondre à la demande toujours plus
croissante la boutique ouverte en 2017
propose aujourd'hui près de 2500
références dont de nombreux objets
dérivés des animaux fantastiques la
nouvelle saga issus de l'univers harry
potter et qui redynamise la franchise
depuis deux ans avec le phénomène des
animaux fantastiques
il ya un une nouvelle une nouvelle vague
de fans
harry potter on à la nouvelle génération
en fait qui connaît pas forcément harry
potter et qui a peut-être lui un harry
potter et qui a regardé animaux
fantastiques
il ya une nouvelle vague en fac à en
train d'arriver la magie d'harry potter
et des animaux fantastiques a également
touché ce magasin culturel des
clayes-sous-bois peluche baguette dvd
surtout une quarantaine de livres sont
mises en avant dans les allées
actuellement on peut retrouver
les animaux fantastiques sous forme de
livre
pour les passionnés les règles du kitsch
pour les plus jeunes un pop up de
poudlard
ainsi poudlard n'aura plus de secrets
pour nos petits lecteurs
chaque semaine plus d'une centaine de
livres sur le célèbre sorcier sont
vendus ici dans cette enseigne
des chiffres qui devraient augmenter l
approche de noël je suis venu pour les
tomes 4 5 6 7 ans ma poche pour ma
technique il veut ça pour noël c'est
parce qu'elle vient de tomber dedans
dans la lecture de ses livres là et donc
à la d'orsan et comme en plus à l'aise
plus de vingt ans après la sortie du
premier livre harry potter ne semble pas
avoir pris une ride auprès des fans et
reste l'une des franchises les plus
puissantes au monde
l'univers aurait engrangé à ce jour près
de 26 milliards de dollars de recettes
depuis son lancement de la musique des
cadeaux et des traditions forcément pour
noël aujourd'hui nous allons un peu
voyagé tout d'abord avec vous grégory
direction l italie et la bad huîtres ni
fois là non pas du tout mes joueurs
assure ses produits tout aussi gourmands
ils sont un peu différents l'or devant
moi vous connaissez forcément le
panettone je vais y voit la preuve
prononcer avec l'accent italien
comment vous dites le panettone nicolas
ballack serait pas mal connaissez c'est
une brioche qui vient donc d'italie une
brioche sucré garni de raisin et fruits
secs ça c'est pour la version classique
car depuis son invention au xvème siècle
a milan il s'est exportée dans toutes
les régions d'italie et s'est déclinée
en plusieurs recettes un restaurant
situé avenue du centre à montigny le
bretonneux qui fait également traiteur
et épicerie fine propose toute une gamme
de panettone venu a dit à lille sont
offrir ou jalabi serons nous encore sans
gluten alors si vous voulez ici on à la
maison oscar pato on est sur un panier
classique uniquement au réseau qu'on
peut avoir des tonnes comme s'amarrer
lafabrie quelques petites cerises
amarena fabrique ces lignes des plus
grandes maisons
la barre et la coop ont l'excellence
rien à dire
après on peut avoir d'autres pas et on
également
je prends par an pour les gens qui
mangent suite sans gluten un petit
manhattan sans gluten aux myrtilles ou
encore une autre maison et vies nos
maisons un peu différent qui est très
très bien aussi
après la dope pas étonnant je vais vous
dire ma remplacé rougerie quotas on fait
un peu toute sorte de panne et a
maintenant bonjour moi il a emballé on
l'a dégustera tout à l'heure en plateau
en italie à noël aussi on apprécie le
chocolat pas n'importe lequel on dit
lajan douilles
nicolas voilà gianduia on peut dire j'en
doute a en france et voilà on reconnaît
là jean dauger acs un peu moins exotique
au chocolat très crémeux aux noisettes
qui nous vient du piémont c'est la base
de la recette d'une célèbre pâte à
tartiner que vous appréciez sans doute
autour de la table est allé dire nicolaj
et non je me permettrai pas nicolas
côtés de ses marques de grande
distribution il ya aussi des marques
reconnues pour leur qualité comme cette
maison turinoise une maison qui
s'appelle benguigui très cool
d'empilement ou là on fait la demoiselle
du monde la belle jeune et très connus
pour leurs petits chocolats mais cuba
torah voilà c'est le nid des principaux
tard ils sont connus alors que vous
allez voir les petits cappuccino je pars
au cappuccino au tiramisu
également et après ils ont également un
peu sa part aussi en doute et les
chocolats on va dire un peu différente
des gens menez ul à ckoi tort différents
goukoye orange qui est pas mal
j'apprécie le panettone si je prononce
bien et emballé juste devant vous me le
donner à nicolas par exemple par hasard
pour l'ouvrir on va lui demander aussi
de couper peut-être commence bien les
deux tranches par contre n'est quà la
tension a pas vous couper un vernis
alors pas que des choses à manger il ya
aussi des choses à boire sur les tables
italiennes d alcool à consommer bien sûr
avec modération
le vent a bien sûr dans les italiens à
dire ont forcément que c'est le meilleur
du monde notamment des vin blanc
pétillant que l'on peut consommer à la
place du champagne
quand vous donnez le savoir en italie a
pas de champagne mais un concurrent le
commenter le secouement tc comme le
champagne sauf que la paroisse
l'appellation champagne classé maison
qui s'appelle bâle coop harousseau très
connu pour les barreaux lobo cia qui est
pour moi l'un des meilleurs vins au
monde
100% des boulots comme le poste comme le
comité s'est également dit de viol au
jeu cépages du barolo ça va être un
petit peu rosé doré moi j'apprécie
beaucoup comparé à un champagne va payer
ça beaucoup moins cher que je trouve que
c'est meilleur
on va terminer avec le meilleur moment
de cette chronique la dégustation alors
que nicolas est en train de déballer de
manière tout à fait discret tout à fait
discrète qui le caractérise comment jean
nouvel en italien natale ça se dit
natale et natal et ça s'écrit voilà
alors le panettone cumul est en train de
déballer saint-palais retour ne dit dans
l'oreillette puisque l'ingénieur du son
est décédé
en train de frotter sa c'est un
panettone aux fruits rouges que pour
vous pouvez retrouver bien sûr dans
l'enseignement je parlais tout à l'heure
à montigny le bretonneux avec d'autres
produits d'ailleurs toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
lien qui s'affiche en bas d'écran
effectivement vous pouvez saupoudrer le
panettone avec se doute qu'elle est le
sucre voilà qui est pour nous un héros
comme tout qui auront comme le chanteur
tout à fait voilà une question sur
l'évolution italienne c'est pas le père
noël chamanique adossés à l'or fin c'est
bien falloir en fait à noël si c'est le
père noël donc on dit babeau natal est
effectivement au moment de l'épiphanie
donc c'est à dire tout début janvier la
befana qui est une sorcière amène
également des cadeaux donc les italiens
ont fait on arrête alors c'est pas
vraiment noël mais ils ont deux fois des
cadeaux alors on saupoudre cola sais pas
si on peut voir en plein droit voilà
effectivement en italie on a une semaine
de congé supplémentaire pour pour fêter
la befana voilà que j'ai me garantissait
que c'est bien du sucre dans le sachet
whitworth écouter nicolas nicolas
il veille à la présentation du colloque
non non vous ne trouvez pas oui mais
voilà nous sommes là parce qu'ici quoi
peut-être continuer pendant donner un
petit coup de main ou on va déguster
pendant l'autre juste après c'est quoi
le goût particulier il ya un groupe
restreint aux fruits rouges alors le
panettones classics et des fruits des
raisins secs et s'est déclinée à
maintenant depuis sa création s'est
déclinée en plusieurs goût des fruits
rouges on en trouve aussi aux marrons
glacés
ben voilà il vraiment enfin au chocolat
tout à fait il ya vraiment plein de boue
et les uns les autres vous avez des
traditions dans vos familles respectives
mais que l'animal de france bleu
provence
ce serait se nourrissent de dessert les
treize desserts de noël par un 13e bol
d'or
c'est les calissons bien sûr aix en
provence parce que j'aime cette ville là
avec les mandarines laissé plein de
petites choses qu'en général je ramène
d'ailleurs après le 1er janvier le géant
barre-de-monts combattants
et on mange bien on a les huîtres à côté
voix sur des traditions
j'ai la chance d'avoir un papa cuisine
et donc je traite pas forcément nicolas
dont il le sud-ouest le fameux foie gras
et puis tous les produits dérivés du
canard donc sans mal gré ou handicapées
vivent les canards morts tous qui canard
nous on voit du prosecco et procès qu un
lobbyiste alliance entre l'alliance et
la pression je veux bien que non
concernant ce italienne oui c'est vrai
tout à fait aux personnes de la coupe et
on goûtera pas tout à l'heure en tout
cas nous partirons du côté du brésil
aussi pour le moment retour à saint
quentin en yvelines qui lance son
premier festival d'humour de 7,8 humour
les nouveaux talents d'un monte sur
scène au prix smile en cours devant le
public devant un jury également première
session qui s'est déjà déroulé c'était
en décembre la prochaine ce sera le 19
février et ce sera et diffusée
prochainement sur tv 78 voici quelques
extraits compilées par roman russe finit
par exemple quand un mec veut prendre un
dernier verre chez moi je dis toujours
non pas parce que j pas une fille facile
je vous rassure c'est une fille mes gars
facile était encore plus facile à
manipuler un ipad tu vas le délit
rappelle je me fais au gema lui mal à
ses copains
il ya des enfants dans la township air
gêné désolé je plaisante y frigide
je veux ça regarde que ce soit l'amour
ou pas c'est pareil donc si je peux
rendre service il est mal monsieur limal
jeu suivante et enfin c'est plaisant mon
coeur appartient à mon père je plaisante
pas quand même encore un mec veut
prendre un dernier verre chez moi mon
corps en vie dit rouillé ma tête dit non
surtout pas de pas voir ça c'est
dégueulasse cela fait des mois que s'est
pas entretenu
je ne parle pas de mon com et de mon
appartement monsieur soyez pas il est
magnifique
il est superbe oui dans l'autre sens où
j'ai eu peur je me suis yount et de vue
je peux dire que j'ai compris en
l'expression donner la vie c'est joli
nom donné la vie la juge s'est fait que
c'est la mienne de vie que je devais
je sais pas vous les meufs mais moi
depuis que j'ai donné la vie je réclame
enfin ma vie on voit là on s'appelle
t'inquiète on savait loi ne te voit que
me parle je pense que ça se voit que tu
parles très optimiste de trois indices
je suis pas habillé en desigual les
desigual tout le monde connaît bien sûr
les fringues dessiné par des aveugles
pour les daltoniens ou parler tout on
saura jamais et en fait j'ai jamais été
optimistes vraiment jamais déjà quand
j'étais petit je l'étais pas quand
j'étais petit j'étais asthmatiques
google asthmatiques pareil tout le monde
doit pour ceux qui voient pas c'est
comme allergiques au gluten
sauf que là c'est vrai
un nouveau club de danse a ouvert un
montini des cours de flamenco sont
proposés à la maison de quartier andré
malraux par l'association passion
lyonnais qui a été créée en juillet 2018
c'est tout récent et nous avons un
plateau avec nous la présidente de
l'association est aussi la costumière
marité là est aussi conçu et le gaillard
de la vice présidente de l'association
bonjour mesdames comment avez-vous eu
l'idée de créer l'association passion et
olé en fait on est toutes les deux
danseuses de flamenco fait on est toutes
les deux aficionados comme on dit en
espagne et on prenait des cours de
flamenco assez loin on a eu envie de
créer ça sur mon kiné bretonneux parce
que j'en avais pas on avait des copines
qui voulant faire avec nous mais qui
pouvaient pas se déplacer aussi loin
donc voilà comme ça on a créé
l'association c'est dire on se lance et
puis on a pas mal de monde qui est
intéressé on a pas mal de nouvelles donc
on est assez contente de de notre
réussite pour l'instant on espère avoir
encore plus de gens et merci à vous de
nous avoir son plateau ce soir alors des
cours pour débutants sont proposés le
mercredi de 18h30 à 20h tandis que les
initiés sont attendus de 20h à 21h30 à
la maison de quartier andré malraux et
justement j'ai testé un de vos cours
avec la professeur de danse vanessa bar
kita je vous laisse découvrir
je me trouve accueil à la salle andré
malraux montigny le bretonneux et vous
l'aurez compris je vais tester de
flamenco danse originaire d'espagne
[Musique]
vanessa je me trouve actuellement dans
votre cours de flamenco vous êtes
professeur de flamenco depuis combien de
temps donc ça fait quinze ans que
l'enseignant
et qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur dans
cette danse de manille libre à les
hanches les pieds en bénéficient c'est
est arrivé
les bras et les pieds parce que dans mon
mouvement des bras on va très justement
par rapport aux pieds qu'on accélère on
va pas la même du zèle
c'est compliqué pour les élèves et pour
les pieds c'est les pieds c'est la
rapidité
non
et on accélère balle sont permis mais
ce travail paraît que les bras et c'est
une danse qui est accessible à tout le
monde
oui à tout le monde à other enfin vos
enfants c'est donc ça se danse en couple
ou seul passage en tout seul en couple
ou sera normalement plus joli c'est à
may hamm est encore sud à 3,4 trèbes
avec vous et je vais essayer tout ça ben
mosbah par là
[Musique]
ah oui
alors vanessa c'est quoi les mouvements
de balais volants de masse ce qui est
important quand on tient bien la jouer
pour la tient bien au bout on ramène à
la taille les pôles vers le bas du coude
vers le haut et le bus en avant d'accord
mais ce qui est important c'est les
frappes qu'on frappe en pointe et on
frappe on frappe pointe et on frappe
parfois on fait sa troisième ayant fait
4 1 1 2 3 4 est en pilote et on repense
au bras à l'épaule en arrière et le
buste en avant et on fait ça on pointe
trappe en pointe par on pointe quatre
pieds plats 1 2 3 4 et en change
vingt deux points 4 on n'oublie pas le
bras 1 2 3 4 des changements vous faites
un deux trois quatre
hélas oui ça va c'est juste les pieds
l'apéritif et après quelques
entraînements c'est parti pour la
chorégraphie avec le chapeau
[Musique]
d
j'ai testé pour les rues de flamenco en
france et ne faut plus que je m'entraîne
un peu sur la rapidité des pieds allez
je retourne
le flamenco est un art espagnol qui se
compose de trois pratiques artistiques
la guitare le chant et la danse comme
vous l'avez vu depuis sa naissance et
arrêt lié à l'histoire aux traditions
andalouses
il occupe aujourd'hui une place
importante dans cette culture régionale
marie conçue et l'eau vous allez nous
danser la sévillane quelle est
l'histoire de cette danse alors la
sévillane fait partie du folklore
andalou à se compose de quatre petites
danses d'une minute à peu près chacune
qui raconte en fait la rencontre
amoureuse donc la première c'est la
rencontre la deuxième la séduction la
troisième dispute est la quatrième et la
réconciliation
on vous montre tout ça tout de suite
place à la danse
[Musique]
greenhalgh
ah non
mais côté de las manos
brive en effet les finales mais pour
hisser la mano
les comparer le nombre et messi
[Musique]
mais suite à la radio oui ma bonne dame
il est
nous aimons
mes 18 ans y travaillent
[Musique]
mamie non viable aussi tous là mais
quimper
bino
[Musique]
mais peu peur c'était mme banon
hélas
la dia
ok d'amener tous les gammes et les
barbes des nano à monter dawn est
également primordial à nos chronos
[Musique]
ouattara
la clé
où est ta personne
si la marée mais lyon
il va sans
thomas
jamais
ma mère aurait commis non
sinon
[Applaudissements]
vous allez je vous ai ramené je vous ai
ramené quelques cobayes vous armer
quelques cobayes micalet voilà on les
laisse moi je vais observer cela de loin
aujourd'hui vous avez mon bras de hockey
alors donc on va danser par deux avec
marie toi tu tenais à être moi il tombe
et là et qui dansent personnes par cours
donc on fait des petits pas de bases
même pied même rare commence par les
pieds gauches fait cinq fois
alors les années vous qu'il soit très
viril très bombée de son avant dernière
comme ça que vous étés bombay bombay
sur un arrière très bien ici on fait des
jolies sort avec les mains on bouge tes
les poignets alors rien ne bouge pas
trop de risques c'est clément cet accord
reste statique d'accord derrière on fait
les pas de base mon cas avec manon d'un
petit peu vue sur tout à l'heure on
essaye on essaye en avant à chacune
pas d'accord
3 c'est bien de sa rage de chars de voir
ça et attention la façade à côté d'un
taux chez soi on se pense et non pas et
pas de base à gauche revient sur les
bras face à grasse qui marche tu fais
comme je l'appelle dans un match si je
tape un petit coup de balai
ce qu'elle viabilité week-end face à la
caméra peut même tourner le dos à tout
le monde qu'elle vient alité pendant que
je vous laisse répéter encore un petit
peu de quelques pas de flamenco ont fait
une petite pause dans cette émission
avec des idées sorties ciné pour les
vacances de fin d'année on est à
quelques jours de maintenant des
vacances de noël et je voulais vous
présenter quelques films qui sont sortis
ou qui vont sortir dans les jours qui
viennent et qui vont vous permettre de
passer de joyeuses fêtes
tout d'abord il ya deux films qui sont
sortis qui sont destinés aux enfants
c'est le grinch et astérix le grinch
c'est naturellement destiné aux jeunes
enfants
la cruche qui essayent de volée noël
donc sa destinée aux jeunes enfants et
puis naturellement notre fameux astérix
ou là on rentre dans une histoire où le
druide panoramix souhaite pas passer un
petit peu la main parce qu'il commence à
se faire un petit peu vieux donc voilà
donc ce sont deux très belles histoires
pour les plus jeunes pour noël et puis
dans les sorties qui vont venir et qui
vont je pense aussi marquer les fêtes de
noël vous avez le retour de mary poppins
quelques cinquante ans plus tard vous
avez les nouvelles aventures de la
célèbre nourrice qui va ravir les plus
jeunes mais aussi les un petit peu les
plus nostalgiques
vous avez aussi un nouveau dc comics qui
va sortir et vous le voyez derrière moi
aquaman aquaman ça me sorte de héros
malgré lui qui va essayer de
réconcilier la terre les habitants de la
terre les habitants des océans pour ceux
qui veulent un petit peu d'action vous
le retrouverez à partir de la semaine du
19 décembre à la fiche
et puis un beau conte aussi de noël là
aussi pour les plus jeunes c'est mia et
le lion blanc
c'est un beau conte de noël où c'est
l'histoire d'une petite fille est qui va
suivre l'évolution d'un lionceau donc là
aussi c'est un très beau conte je vous
encourage à le découvrir pour les
vacances de noël
et puis pour ceux qui le 1er janvier
après quelques fêtes où quelques petites
coupes de champagne aurait envie de
venir au cinéma je vous annonce l'avant
première exceptionnelle de qu'est-ce
qu'on a encore fait au bon dieu où vous
retrouverez la fin du gouverneur ils ont
de nouvelles aventures
donc c'est le 1er janvier à 18 heures
une seule séance
n'hésitez pas à réserver dès maintenant
mais quand même vraiment gatti debré
corde
moi j'ai du mal avec la france et avec
odile là on a décidé de s'installer en
israël
vraiment on part en chine un contenu en
algérie par abondé à bombay le drapeau
du bercail rabouli le pays où les gens
se prosterne devant les vaches c'est la
solution nos gendre n'aime plus la
france
on va leur faire aimer la france
décidément vous famille nous réserve
toujours de belles surprises
on va récupérer un peu du flamenco en
attendant tout à l'heure de se lancer
dans le crossfit est-ce que c'est aussi
physique quelqu'un à dos c'est un
mélange entre regina si de cardio et
haltérophilie donc c'est très complet
vous êtes prêts michael c'est pour moi
c'est bon c'est pour vous qu'on la fait
bien évidemment
en attendant parlons solidarité chaque
année les associations oeuvrent pour
assurer de meilleures fêtes de fin
d'année aux plus démunis les
municipalités également comme attrape le
reportage de manoeuvre à dos des seniors
heureux le sourire aux lèves toucher
grâce à la distribution de colis de noël
elle était organisée à la salle des
quatre saisons en mairie de trappes la
ville de trappes est plutôt plus connu
pour sa son extrême jeunesse mais nous
avons aussi quand même 3200 personnes
âgées enfin ce qu'on appelle les seniors
maintenant et donc sur ce 3200 personnes
nous voulons les honorer et les
remercier d'être les seniors avaient le
choix entre deux sortes de colis de noël
les rouges constitué de provisions salée
et les colis noir exclusivement sucre et
une petite attention très importante
pour les anciens ça fait toujours
plaisir de recevoir un produit quand on
est seul
les enfants sont un peu dispersé donc je
n'en tout tout seul à trappes
ça fait chaud au coeur le colis s'est
fait une joie cette heure attachement
aux événements qui se passent dans la
ville c'est une très bonne idée de la
ville de trappes de
de donner un petit quelque chose à celle
qu les personnes qui n'ont pas bénéficié
des colis sont conviés un banquet
organisé par la ville de trappes 300
personnes sont invitées
michael est ce que vous connaissez votre
meilleur profil un meilleur profil une
silhouette y sera vraiment si webkit qui
va vous qui va nous aiguiller sur ça
peut-être
ah oui tout à fait révolte fridge vous
propose de découvrir le métier donc deux
silhouettes east c'est pas facile à dire
une pratique très répandue à l'époque de
la cour au xviie siècle qui a presque
disparu avec l'arrivée la photographie
il est en cause ce cas est venu et de
versailles pour nous présenter son
métier
bonsoir ça alors pourquoi vous êtes
lancés dans cette aventure
alors c'est mon père et mon grand-père
qui sont donc silhouette east donc c'est
une tradition familiale et je ne pensais
pas que ça allait devenir mon métier je
les fais par passion
g je les fais en parallèle de mes études
j'ai commencé à travailler un peu dans
l'événementiel et n'agit pas mal de
demander pas mal de succès j'ai commencé
à collaborer avec des avec des agences
événementielles et puis des maisons de
luxe françaises et puis voilà et puis
j'ai commencé à faire mon petit mon
petit réseau et c'est comme ça que j'ai
créé la marque la silhouette east et
j'essaye du coup de montrer mon art de
le revivre un petit de le faire revivre
en tout cas il vous fait des silhouettes
depuis cointrin du coup ça doit faire
une dizaine d'années que je suis
professionnel parce que pouvons nous
faire une petite démonstration
bien sûr les téléspectateurs
vous avez marine et d'un côté parce
qu'elle a un bon profil oui oui bien sûr
est-ce que vous avez gardé votre chapeau
rouge blanc vert
il faut combien de temps pour faire
moins de trois minutes de trois minutes
3 pour finir et et vous intervenez
auprès de particuliers
vous exercez votre à quel moment en fait
c'est lors de soirées événementielles
donc par exemple pour des mares de luxe
pour les lancements de produits d
inauguration de magasins
je collabore avec 6 aussi avec des des
palaces parisiens quand il donc il me
propose en fait à leurs invités
la simod de plusieurs personnalités
nomme oui tout à fait oui paris par
exemple forestois la forêt soit au coeur
jennifer lopez
là je me souviens plus je pense que
c'est mon instagram ce serait ça c'était
pas tous en tête mais oui quelques-uns
mais qu'est-ce qui est le plus difficile
à faire dans une silhouette n'est pas
vraiment de difficultés c'est vraiment
je préfère les profils avec le plus le
caractère ça ressemble à ça ressort plus
plus facilement que commencer quand
c'est plus simple en fait bien ce qu'il
faut beaucoup d'entraînement ou pas oui
parce que l'on vous voit faire ça paraît
après presque presque simple c'est parce
que c'est un âge 1,6 au numérique
aujourd'hui c'est pousser quelqu'un
ciseaux or quelques coups de ciseaux
c'est fait voilà est-ce que je suis
presque terminée on va pouvoir ne soit
pas trop anxieuse le résultat a l'air
d'être là qui aperçoit déjà il faut
savoir avoir beaucoup c'est beaucoup de
minutie
forcément oui mais ça c'est une des
premières choses d'abord c'est
l'observation et ensuite
et ensuite l'entraînement pour pouvoir
coordonner il vous a fallu quelques
secondes pour jacques on peut
effectivement le résultat et fois la
face à la caméra
c'est encore mieux voilà il a confirmé
voulu reconnaître l'élection
je ne vois pas souvent se profile dans
le négatif vous allez rester encore avec
nous encore un peu peut-être pour vous
livrer un autre exercice quel sera le
cobaye le prochain dit enjeux qui se
lance bertrand c'est que ça s est
compliquée qu'elle soit si vous inspire
le plus vous voulez vous lancer avec nos
amis qu'elle soit en phase bon après ce
sera pas officiel ça c'est pour moi la
faire partager aux autres mélanie vous
allez nous parler un petit peu de refus
de l'art de la table recevoir bien
recevoir à table parle alors déjà bien
recevoir en parlait surtout de
décoration de table parce que pour faire
sa décoration de table il faut penser
avant tout à son mobilier s'en inspirer
par exemple sur les images que l'on va
voir à l'écran les scénographes du cfa
de saint germain en laye se sont
inspirés du tapis un tapis qui peut
faire penser un parquet qui est de style
moderne mais on peut aussi jouer avec
l'esprit de la pièce là cette table est
dressée au coeur du domaine de madame
elisabeth qui est donc très classique
plutôt royal il fallait donc apporter
une certaine touche contemporaine il
sait comment ce que les gens pensent pas
c'est que c'est c'est pas une décoration
de cap c'est une décoration de table
dans une pièce donc si vous faites une
décoration qui n'a absolument rien à
voir avec tout le décor vous avez à côté
vous risquez de passer à côté
ici la vaisselle on a fait un choix de
du départ et âge pour les assiettes mais
il faut absolument avoir quand même un
fil conducteur vous ne peut pas tous des
paris alors le petit conseil de laurent
tanguy c'est aussi d'anticiper les
décorations en fonction des dépôts de
plat alors surtout ne changez pas votre
table de décoration puisque si vous
allez les enlever juste
avant de manger c'est un peu dommage
vous allez gâcher leur pas que vos
convives
si on doit poser des plats dessus on va
pouvoir décorer tout autour de découvert
le set de table le verre l'acier tapin
garder la partie centrale relativement
vide ou si comme aujourd'hui
ah ben on va utiliser tout l'espace et
la tendance de cette année c'est le
végétal et victoire la nature de manière
subtile wilfried on va amener un peu de
gaieté pourquoi ne pas récupérer les
feuilles tombées des arbres dès bouts de
bois des branches des pommes de pin mais
il faut choisir un élément pour le
décliner sous différentes formes au
positionnement couches et pots 0
couverts etc
alors les végétaux peuvent même servir
de groen serviette pour cette table
décoration à base d'animaux dans des
petits pots carré deux techniques sont
possibles lautoka l'âge c'est à dire que
les fleurs se tiennent entraîne grâce au
vase est la technique la plus simple
c'est la technique la plus simple par
nos ou alors on peut aussi utiliser de
la pousse de fleuriste épique et les
fleurs dedans
l'important pour un stand au top c'est
qu'il faut pas trop où elle a autant
maximum par rapport au sol à la table
c'est 30 centimes est un transit audimat
étant vraiment déjà assez haut il faut
pas que les convives sur un génie par
des fleurs mais il existe une exception
nous pouvons très bien avoir une coupe
sur pied très route avec une composition
tout en hauteur au niveau du visuel il
faut que les convives puissent toujours
recevoir
alors attention la décoration de table
n'est pas forcément un centre de table
on peut totalement l'excentré là bien
sûr l'important bien sûr vu le fric vous
en doutez c'est de se faire plaisir et
de partager un bon repas pour ces
quelques conseils que vous pourriez nous
donner est ce que
non pas vous êtes décoration de table je
vais pas de les creuser dans votre
intimité mais est-ce que vous avez
terminé notamment tourné comme j'ai
paniqué vous êtes très bien de ce côté
pas ma place
le détail de la barbe c'est plus que
ressemblant et c'est très bien réussi
merci fait l'incitation un instant g
d'armes au site internet pour trouver
celle où est-il que la silhouette
isséens paname la silhouette et sur
internet ses recettes nombreux
nombreuses à faire ce métier on a envie
maintenant non plus mais il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont plus de la
génération de mon père aujourd'hui est
que ma soeur et moi et voilà
quelques-uns on est vraiment très très
peu ce sont plutôt les hommes d'ailleurs
qui les cible est à l'époque exactement
métier de femme mais je trouvais que
c'était un petit challenge de donner un
petit peu de finesse et un peu d'amour à
cet art vous avez déjà des demandes pour
juste pas noël animé la soirée d'un
réveillon
oui oui j'en ai et là je suis en grosse
période de justement je fais pas mal
d'événements pour des maisons de luxe
notamment leurs branches de noël
oui je suis beaucoup beaucoup s'arrêtait
pas j'arrête paraît donc on peut en
vivre
vous arrivez à vivre de cette profession
trompe l'on vivrait et vous cherchez à
donner peut-être des cours dans des
écoles alors que le second métier se
conserve connaître que dans un deuxième
temps j'aimerais bien transmettre au hip
hop peut-être des élèves qui sont en
école d'art et à faire une formation à
peu restreint d'autant que peut-être je
sais pas une dizaine vingtaine d'élèves
mais oui ce sera avec plaisir que je
transmettrai pour pas perdre exact comme
certains disparaissent aujourd'hui il ya
des acteurs évoluent si vous voulez
prendre des cours baby g franchement je
suis passé à bild
ce tweak des ciseaux vous connaissez je
suis très à gauche maintenant
à côté d'elle merci beaucoup merci à
vous on poursuit cette huit spéciales
fin d'année avec dans quelques instants
nicolas landry qui nous donnera quelques
conseils pour déguster de bons vins avec
modération bien évidemment mais
peut-être chercher vous encore un cadeau
de dernière minute un cadeau pour les
étrennes
et bien la rédaction vous propose de
découvrir sur notre antenne et sur notre
site internet également à 7,8 dossier
consacré aux produits made in yvelines
petit avant goût avec ce reportage
consacré à la toile de jouy qui a su se
renouveler au fil du temps elle est la
création d'un homme oberkampf qui la
fabrique à partir de 1760 à jouy en
josas la toile de jouy est apprécié à
l'époque pour sa grande qualité et la
précision de ses dessins le tissu est
très vite prisé par la bourgeoisie et la
noblesse française
le succès de la toile de jouy
tiens à la proximité de jouy en josas
avec le château de versailles
christophe philippe oberkampf était un
visionnaire tendant
les motifs et d'un point de vue créatif
que dans sa gestion industrielle de la
manufacture la cour qui étaient
effectivement à proximité rafale et de
sa production si aujourd'hui l'indienne
ne se fabriquent plus dans sa ville
d'origine ces motifs célèbre se décline
en de nombreux produits dérivés au sein
du musée de la toile de jouy une
boutique où l'on peut trouver chaussures
bijoux trousse ou encore de la vaisselle
les plateaux qui ont été fait cette
année dans un motif bengale et ce choix
était fait surtout pour les couleurs que
manuel canovas utilise donc dans un ton
dans les tons aubergines
nous avons aussi une autre collection
des tôles qui a été fait dans un motif
dont qui a été pris dans les fonds
muséal dans le motif de l'offrande à
l'amour
donc nous avons quatre coloris qui ont
été fait cette année donc dans ce rouge
basque
un rose pompe et un vert de gris à
chaque saison sa collection pour
l'automne hiver le produit phare cette
année c'est une marinière créé en
partenariat avec la marque armor lux un
vêtement fabriqué à l'occasion de
l'exposition sur le peintre franco
japonais fujita qui se tient en ce
moment au musée de la toile de jouy
nous avons repris donc le motif
de l'art d'aimer que vous jugez pas
utiliser énormément dans ses oeuvres et
nous avons décidé de reprendre le bateau
donc un petit sinagot qui a été mise
dans les
dans les coudes hier
des marines deux marques sont
disponibles dans la boutique collection
et création du musée de la toile de jouy
et pour panser ses produits
l'inspiration ne manquent pas au musée
qui possède un fonds de 10000 pièces de
toile de jouy des beignets effectivement
dans tous ces dessins je m'en lasse pas
je trouve toujours des choses nouvelles
c'est d'une richesse incroyable pour moi
ce que j'aime aussi beaucoup faire c'est
justement retravaillé tous les motifs
que nous avons dans les réserves
notamment les empreintes aussi les
choses fabuleuses
donc ça je décline avec sort énormément
de papeterie aussi dans la boutique il y
en a pour tous les goûts et pour toutes
les bourses conti de 3 à 200 euros pour
ses produits au motif de la toile venue
de jouy en josas un bon cadeau une bonne
bouteille c'est votre philosophie
nicolas effectivement l'alcool ça monte
à la tête et ça débris dans l'est les
personnes et c'est important pour les
fêtes de fin d'année noël le jour de
l'an et du coup vous pouvez allez vous
rendre chez ce caviste les coques du vin
c'est à montfort l'amaury et il présente
notamment une gamme de whisky les
whiskys de différents types existent
vous pourriez par hasard à voir des
choses qui sont plutôt sur de foin coupé
la céréale la douceur où vous pourriez
avoir des chutes chose marin que musclé
plus sur des tons salins heroes day
lewis qui dajla par exemple sont
typiques de cette région là de cette
façon de ce savoir-faire écossais alors
on voit que le savoir-faire écossais
c'est vraiment dur ces marins je sais
pas si vous vous avez ce temps tveit
vous préférez plutôt le whisky debout ou
le whisky brusquer les rues d'où qu'ils
soient et où qu'ils soient et bien moi
je vous propose d'aller aux états unis
parce qu'en fait en écosse on écrit
whisky avec un y
mais aux états unis c'est oui ce cas on
va tester votre accent mais michael
barry sky
voilà et à votre avis à ses cris comment
du coup je ne sais pas avec un pays non
risqués avec kayak y voilà exactement
et oui sky et donc des couvées on peut
découvrir notamment les particularités
de du whisky américain là nous serons
sur quelque chose qui n'a pas d'ordre
maltais nous serons sur le maïs le
seigle le bleu est alors il ya aussi un
autre alcool le rhum je pense plutôt à
marange et oui mais alors on va juste
leur préciser j'ai oublié de le dire
tout ça avec modération voit bien
dans un esprit festif mais avec
modération et donc leur oms et les
caraïbes
c'est la chaleur les tropiques et
notamment il ya des rhums arrangés avec
une gamme aussi assez importante dans ce
magasin on propose plusieurs choix
différent si contingent bronze lio
ananas victoria où mon préféré
vanille noix de macadamia mais qu'est ce
que vous faites après l'apéritif
ils voulaient me proposait un rameau au
gingembre oui peut-être comme vous
voulez là aussi on reste toujours dans
le côté mystique du gingembre et
l'apéritif à sa table mais on passe à
table et alors qu'est ce qu'on prend à
table champagne ben oui pour terminer
vous à lunettes et alors vous
accompagner avec quoi par exemple en
termes de nourriture alors vin blanc
fruits de mer vin rouge viandes et
fromages le champagne tout le temps ce
qui allait coûter propose d'écouter les
conseils de ce cas liste pour nous la
spécialité de la maison c'est les grands
meunier et pinot meunier donc page assez
inhabituel rarement mis en avant et qui
fait des vins extrêmement fruité et avec
beaucoup beaucoup de place beaucoup
beaucoup de finesse de complexité
lorsque nous a précisé ce caviste c'est
que le vin qui vient de présenter
il est complet enfin il est polyvalent
c'est à dire qu'on peut le manger avec
du foie gras de la viande blanche du
gibier plus mais aussi 4 au numéro
j'aurais plus c'est très bien pour
éviter les maux de tête même le fromage
est alors avec le fromage il a aussi une
autre idée pour vous là on est sur la
loire avec agnès et rené mosse sur
cépage chenin donc un peu un peu la star
de la région et qu'est ce qui sera très
agréable notamment sur les brebis
les chèvres des fromages pas trop
affiner mes mails accord l'accord est
évident avec avec lui tant de damas
joyeux noël à vous et toute votre
famille santé et n'oubliez pas de
consommer avec modération
[Musique]
alors comme il vient de le dire surtout
avec modération et je vous propose une
dernière petite curiosité c'est un c'est
un whisky japonais alors très rare et du
coup la chair à votre avis à votre avis
combien coûte cette bouteille le quartie
milliards milliers d'euros 1000 euros
ouais je dirais 2000 aux 5000 euros vous
n'êtes pas loin grégory 6500 sais plus
et moi c'est le vendeur m'a dit que
cette bouteille pouvait monter jusqu'à
6000 euros puis à 6000 euros
parce que c est donc c'est ça qui fait
la force et la cherté d'un alcool c'est
plus il est vieux plus à l'idée de
qualité et donc plus cher il est donc
pas merci pour ces quelques conseils à
ses cabistes et puis une fois de plus un
trou cela avec modération nous parlions
tout à l'heure des traditions des
traditions de noël en italie avec vous à
grégory nous allons partir un peu plus
loin à présent au brésil plus
précisément et guillaume et et kevin
taurin deux frères ont décidé de faire
80 mille kilomètres à vélo de parcourir
le monde pendant là trois ans ils sont à
rio en ce moment ils sont partis de bois
d'arcy nous en avions parlé d'ailleurs
sur ce plateau et ils nous parlent de
leurs réveillant le tour du monde à vélo
nous voici donc au brésil après huit
mille quatre cent cinquante kilomètres
je pense qu'on va fêter noël dans ce
pays ça a l'air de se soucier pénale
vraiment vite pour aller en uruguay mais
ça on ne croit pas après avoir traversé
la france l'espagne le portugal le maroc
la mauritanie le sénégal et puis une
traversée en voilier nous voici donc
sous le soleil du brésil pour peut-être
fêter noël et ben oui oui c'est ici
qu'on va fêter noël entre rio de janeiro
et sao paulo dont ceux patrouille à un
petit suspense sur ça on va continuer de
pédaler donc on va voir comment les
fêtes de fin d'année vont se passer pour
nous en tout cas ce qui est assez
déroutant c'est que on est en plein
soleil il fait 30 degrés et on est en
short d'ong et pourtant voilà il ya des
saponines à l'esprit de noël est ici et
ça fait
ça fait plaisir c'est rigolo c'est
vraiment atypique on va fêter noël
on sait pas trop où encore bien notre
mère qui est venue nous rejoindre
quelques jours ici mais elle est
repartie elle pour les fêtes en france
on va voir où est ce qu'on va fêter ça
ce sera peut-être chez l'habitant
peut-être sous la tente on va essayer
peut-être avec des voyageurs à vo qui
s'est en tout cas on reste très ouvert
et on va trouver
une façon originale à nous de fêter noël
merci beaucoup à tous merci atp 118 à
tous les téléspectateurs de tv soixante
dix huit ans vous souhaite d'excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année qui forcément mais
on se retrouve une dernière fois autour
de cette table pour évoquer le noël des
animaux à présent ont eux aussi fait
noël avec la spa chaque année un
événement d'envergure se déroule à paris
place de la république avec la
mobilisation des gilet jaune cette année
la spa est due à l'annuler elle a
demandé à tous ceux qui avaient un
projet d'adoption de se rendre dans les
refuges directement nous sommes allés à
plaisir pour rencontrer les bénévoles
les salariés qui oeuvrent écouter
marie-laure carmes
la responsable le but de la spa c'est
que l'adoption soit une une adoption
responsable réfléchit donc on a on a
l'habitude de poser toujours les mêmes
questions qui me permettent de cibler
l'importance de l'adoption et de la
projeter aussi sûr sûr sûr le futur on
leur parle bien sûr des vacances parce
qu'il ya toujours le problème des
vacances que faire pendant les vacances
quand on a un animal
donc voilà dans fait à cette période là
on fait très attention mais le reste de
l'année aussi la spa qui rappelle tout
de même qu offrir un animal à noël se
pense en amont c'est un engagement au
quotidien hors de question de les
abandonner à nouveau on s'en doute pour
le week end d'adoption à noël cette
année 967 animaux ont trouvé une
nouvelle la famille en france et il en
reste encore vous êtes plutôt chiens
chats chiens je suis un chien chat h
alors un chat je vous présente étonne
regardez il cherche une famille donc
elton qu'on a appris à connaître ses
besoins donc c'est un chat qui est vif
extrêmement présent et donc qui aura
certainement besoin de plus tôt de vivre
en pavillon ça c'est très important
les nombreux chats qui ne s'adaptent pas
la vie en appartement et c'est souvent
une résine d'abandon donc nous
effectivement l'idée c'est vraiment
d'adopter dufernez d'options responsable
sur le long terme avec le moins de
risque de retour possible
elton vous a séduit il est mignon pour y
fêter peut-être qu'il va trouver une
nouvelle une nouvelle familiale et pour
ceux qui préfèrent les chiens j'en ai un
petit dernier lui aussi attend
impatiemment une famille et il n'a pas
eu un parcours facile parce que l aspa
aussi il ya des urgences des sos com
appel pour ces animaux un pinscher cette
fois-ci regardez c'est une petite chaîne
qui à peu près huit ans une pinscher qui
arrivé au refuge il ya quelques mois
déjà
elles étaient obèses c'est une petite
chaîne qui avait aucune contrainte qui
divisera qu'une personnes âgées et on a
eu beaucoup de mal à faire à le faire
prendre confiance en nous elle était
extrêmement hargneuse agressive un petit
peu tous goûtés refuge et petit à petit
elle prend ses habitudes
alors l'idée c'est pas qui a fini ses
jours on refuse parce que c'est une
potiche est très rigolote qui est
extrêmement intelligente
la preuve c'est qu'il ya une très
mauvaise façon de se présenter aux
adoptants tout ce qu'elle ne connaît pas
elle va d'office se montrait hargneuse
et c'est une petite chienne qu'on
placera pas avec des jeunes enfants
parce qu'elle peut pincer
donc il faut des connaisseurs du
pinscher parce que le pinscher la de
base sont des chiens à forte
personnalité et comment se passe une
adoption
quelles sont les familles et les
responsabilités que vous aurez lorsque
vous vous présenter marie laure caron à
nouveau quand on vient dans un refuge
ont fait remplir un petit document qui
nous permet de savoir dans quelles
conditions vivra le chien ou le chat
pour cibler en fait au mieux possible
animal qui peut intéresser les gens
puisque le but en fait c'est de trouver
l'animal qui va correspondre aux besoins
et
vice versa à la famille et donc on
demande une participation de 250 euros
pour l'adoption d'un chien 300 euros
pour un chiot et 150 euros pour un chat
ils sont identifiés vaccinés stérilisés
et si vous voulez adopter vous pouvez
contacter le centre de plaisir où
quelques-uns des 62 autres refuges sur
la totalité de l'année à 2017 38000
adoption se sont déroulés c'est bien
mais le meilleur moyen bien évidemment
de ne pas faire souffrir ses animaux
c'est de ne pas les abandonner de
réfléchir avant vous avez des animaux
chacun chacune oui un chien un chien son
new yorker qui s'appelle uno uno michael
il est déjà venu à la rédaction la
diriger voilà j'ai un petit chez un
petit carlin mais je les donner à mes
parents parce qu'ils avaient un grand
jardin et en appartement donc je vais le
voir c'est un peu la garde alternée
quand ils partent en vacances c'est à
dire des galères et ainsi de suite voilà
et il s'appelle fine fine finit quand
même dire qu'il ya un lien on va
retrouver à présent 1 marlène pour
terminer cette émission avec une séance
de crossfit
et maintenant qu'on a vu comment bien
manger pour noël on va voir comment
récupérer tout ça alors avec moi
j'essaie à cabris bonjour on va parler
cros suite avec vous mais le nu pour en
parler avant de commencer tout ça c'est
d'aller voir ses adeptes je me suis
rendu chez farmer training une nouvelle
salle dédiée au crossfit qui est ouvert
en septembre à la ferme des épis noirs à
plaisir ce sens je suis convié
du coup via mon métier faut que je
m'entraîne et du coup le crossfit c'est
un mélange de tout gym
haltéro endurance cardio du coup c'était
bon compromis quoi ça change tous les
jours on n'a jamais le mot donc du coup
il n'y a pas de rang kent et de
lassitude voilà on peut jamais les mêmes
exercices ca / précieux les joueurs
ouais mais du coup c'est sûr des bonnes
surprises parce que bon voila quand on
est motivé pas forcément ça fait que
l'on vient et puis voilà on verra c'est
comme le cadeau du père noël ont déballé
on voit ce que ça donne
alors comme nous l'ont dit les deux
sportifs il ya un programme différent à
chaque cours dans le jardin crossfit on
appelle ça un world pour work out of the
day ou super accent anglais c'est quoi
exactement expliquez moi comment on fait
les programmes ça change vraiment à
chaque fois exactement en fait il ya une
programmation qui est fait sur le moyen
et long terme
nous on sait où on veut amener les gens
on veut comme en ville et les éduquer au
niveau sportif et du coup après en
divisant petites séquences et donc
chaque jour est une nouvelle séquence
pour justement faire progresser la
condition physique générale crossfit
généralement ça semble très intense dont
on va même voir un peu des images easy
vont bien mais c'est quand même adaptés
au niveau de chacun
exactement c'est ça la magie du crossfit
en fait la magie du crossfit c'est que
on peut être débutant on peut être un
peu initiés on peut être élite
on peut être handicapé on peut être
blessé toutes les toutes les solutions
sont possibles en fait chaque mouvement
va pouvoir être déclinée pour pouvoir
réadapter à chaque personne en fonction
de son niveau c'est pour se maintenir en
forme pour aller encore plus loin c'est
vraiment en fonction des niveaux avoir
des attentes différentes en se rendant
un coup de crosse fils exactement alors
vous avez quand même une petite
particularité c'est qu'en plus du
crossfit vous ajoutez du yoga exactement
alors le yoga c'est
c'est quelque chose qui va permettre de
travailler beaucoup plus en profondeur
on va travailler beaucoup plus le
gainage on va pouvoir travailler la
souplesse l'équilibré des choses qu'on
travaille un petit peu moins en crossfit
ou de façon plus rapide alors que l'on
va vraiment prendre le temps au yoga et
aussi prendre le temps de travail et sa
concentration est vraiment le retour sur
soi qui permet justement d'être encore
meilleurs après sur les autres activités
comme un creux suite non mais nous ce
soir on va pas se détendre en faisant du
yoga je pense qu'on va essayer le
crossfit
moi j'invite mes collègues m'ont rejoint
les plus téméraires et encore moins les
meilleurs spécimens de la rédaction
alors je vous ai préparé un petit cadeau
au pied du sapin c'est sympa mais voilà
donc comme là vous avez aimé les
chansons un matériel qui s'appelle le
catel belle le catal belle qui est donc
en anglais ça veut dire une cloche en
eau et qui est lesté donc qui pèse un
certain poids donc il ya plusieurs
tailles pour plusieurs clubs anglais
avec le petit déjà eros bolivie n'est ce
pas 8h12 et comme je vous disais donc
quand vous arrivez dans la salle vous
avez donc un programme un nouveau
programme tous les jours comme ça c'est
un mode de toujours tout à fait ça c'est
un walk out of the day donc là nous
avons 80 en quatre tours donc on parle
toujours en anglais en gros suite ok
c'est le code comme le code de la route
c'est voilà donc qu'on parle en anglais
nous avons 80 ou de 9,6 top 6 gobelets
de squats et trois birdies le jargon
fait que je vais vous expliquer c'est
très simple
les filles se sont mises en robe et ont
fait exprès et en talons en plus à ma
part n'est pas pouvoir faire certains
mouvements tels que le site up j'aurais
dû allons considérer des tables le site
qu'on peut se placer donc sur le dos sur
le dow les filles les filles vous
réalité du coup ça va les gars ans sur
le dos sur le dos pour me donne tout à
fait avec les micros et tous ses prêts
c'est parfait
et les pieds jean fléchit les genoux en
ouverture là vous allez amener les pieds
l'un contre l'autre cette façon oui le
plus simple serait encore monter vos
amis est d'accord officiel
[Musique]
vous saviez vous alliez faire du sport
non non non martèle estime je vous
trouvez un autre cobaye
on va toucher loin derrière et on va
ramener mais maintenant c'est pas beau
mais non mais non
d'ailleurs avec la veste c'est une base
non ça ne peut pas être je ne peux pas
faire ça vous fait ça très bien à
grégory en faire mieux qu'à ça
c'est le site up
ok ça veut dire ça allait s'asseoir en
fait tout simplement
ok très bien vraiment jamais m'asseoir
tout ça bravo grégory mon dos ne suis
pas au bled squattent les filles vont
pouvoir le faire
tiens je vous en prie ne parle est
squatté 1,8 kg alors nous tenons à nous
tenons le cattle comme un gobelet donc
entrer demain
d'où le nom gobelet toi tard pour
médecine autres des pieds largeur des
épaules et nous allons faire un squat le
squat c'est la flexion des sang et or
vente ne prend pas jusqu'où est ce que
c'est le pantalon problème on imagine
qu'on a un gobelet entre les mains il
faut surtout pas le faire tomber
il est rempli d'eau bouillante
c'est plutôt bien surtout je me rends
compte que vous n'avez pas dit encore là
donc ça ça je peux le faire
prix juste les jambes oui allez on place
les
mon en temps ça va être compliqué mais
mais non en tant que danseuse hors
martinair temps ce flamenco
alors on pousse les anges des gérants
vers l'arrière et ensuite on plie les
jambes en descendent et c'est en
descendant des savants des savants des
sang et or on a bien bravo belle mobile
très très bien donc
ensuite vous pouvez poser et nous avons
le fameux beurre puis internationale que
tout le monde adore n'est ce pas si on
ne parle pas du tout mais c'est vrai nom
est bon et bien leurs prises ont placé
main au sol en grenouille en grenouille
va se coucher par terre
oh bah oui alors on ira en quart
non mais on se met alors donc nous en
avons neuf du premier six du deuxième et
trois du troisième et donc ensuite nous
avons quatre tours à faire en tout ça
c'est la routine c'est une routine
possible donc on y va on essaie quand
même mois en amont alors non au moins un
tour mais pas ici on peut maintenant si
c'est pas grave les filles vous allez
faire un gainage à la place regarder
mais voilà comme ça là c'est plus simple
pendant que les garçons il faut les six
textes on y va je ne peux pas faire je
ne vois pas ça marche
ok fait partie allait il y en a pouvait
refaire de gens n'ont rien à neuf en
effet les huit ans voilà donc là il faut
bien expiré pour monter doit-on repose
sur vous grégory mais alors le problème
c'est que si ma lentement et filles à
attendre non mais attends je sais pas
combien
je pense qu'il reste trois là encore
deux encore un hacker le prochain tour
sera plus rapide
ok en biscuit en couches interrompre en
lego on prend les quais seul et on fait
les gobelets de quoi tu parles de frais
assez bien fait intime c'est allez c'est
parti en a six
on y va et tac est remonté deux c'est
parti ça soit 4,5 et 6,5 et ans repose
on fait les beurs peas y en a trois pour
tout le monde c'est parti échauffement
et hautement elle continuera hors
antenne pour la suite de la iglesia du
cours de crossfit
merci beaucoup à nos invités sont venus
au tout au long de cette émission
spéciale fin d'année merci au
journaliste chroniqueur qui était
présent aux équipes techniques également
réalisations signées roman à rusvinyl le
journal revient en direct on vous
retrouvera le 2 janvier d'ici là passez
de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année merci à
tous est fait
[Musique]